I wanted a story today because he's the
reason why the worst possible thing you
can do with this topic is treat it as
sort of random arbitrary set of rules
that you've got a word and then
mechanically apply to a set of also
arbitrary and random letters yeah so I
really am desperate for you to month a
purchase price because we can spend the
better part of the next two years
learning ahead a play in fact you guys
probably are aware of is that much but
you're eating a batch right it's not the
laws they look mad
there are levels below it there's a
general mass and there was other costs
before corn that's the society and that
kind of thing the big difference between
two or three point and those forces is
this in fact to unit three and they are
called the calculus courses okay and you
can actually give your programmer
have a look at the syllabus and others
say that 30 topics so I'm gonna make you
in a way so it gets you appreciating the
wonderful discount this is not a set of
random rules that are invented by my
business your torch okay I used to think
that okay and then when would you Bessie
actually learned it about what I'm about
how this is not ready to the most every
minute
actually they were a set of insights put
together by 12 depending on which
history community one or more Jesus to
solve what was insoluble problems in the
universe okay really okay and you guys
by doing this topic you can think the
thoughts of those brightest minds in the
universe after them okay so when you're
doing appreciation please don't get
that's just it's just I have to do this
because the soft mind the water studies
aside that's what are your legs means so
where does the story stop well here's
the story maybe you can tell me this is
my guy a special a lot of different
things what he's most famous for though
is that he had a puzzle whatever you
think that she fell on his head on
thought is but everyone basically agrees
that leaf looked an apple a short form
and he said the apples in the sky wall
in the industry and then it falls why
doesn't it fall why doesn't it
eventually one day crash it down to the
other just like every other object what
are you going to sell for what if I
threw some was it must actually be fine
right just like the Apple but it must be
doing something else which results from
actually
so you want to figure out this and it
realized it had to do with they knew
about Rapids and how it works because
debate but what it used that if you
think about the force of gravity okay
and how much gravity is being exerted on
something it changes the amount of
gravity on something like say an apple
all of the food I think changes we can
further away okay so grab these
structures when you you're zero distance
from something we don't actually
standing on the surface of the earth
okay that's when it's grabbing at
universe if you go away from the earth
that that gravitational watch starts to
decrease and if you will say two times
further than Wagoneer
the rabbit is half and if you're four
times away will be sixteen times when we
come and it tapers off like this okay
that he was his problem you want to
think about this and particularly yes
how this being relates to an object
moving because but you couldn't do any
masculine and here use the problem he
wants to know how his grabby thing
changes the distance okay
but he had no way to express or
calculate what that change was because
we know how to talk about change when
things are straight okay because like an
eBay in corn geometry we learned that to
change we call it gradients right so we
say if you have two points on a straight
line
if you can work out how far it goes up
which we call rise and how far they go
across which we call if you divide one
by the other then you'll get over a
gradient or the slants for the how much
is lives changing obviously okay but the
problem with this guy is that if you
take different points I'd say this one
in this one okay
or if you took at this one this one or
any two different points this grating
business would change it would always be
different the gradient wasn't a number
right in this case the gradient was just
a a constant term okay here the grading
itself was always changing the gradient
itself was a function the other been
removed it functions and relations it's
something which you put inputs in like
say the distance where you are and it
will change right so the rate that we
call it the gradient function as opposed
to just so